so the Prime Minister warned MP's not to
obstruct the brexit process before their
debate on the bill to trigger its the
process of leaving the EU now the latest
poll shows the majority of the public
support to resumes approach but brexit
is viewed very differently in some of
the countries she'll soon be negotiating
with a little earlier I spoke to Zoltan
Kovich spokesman for the prime minister
of Hungary I began by asking him about
the upcoming elections in several
European countries this year this year's
going to be the age of the age or year
of revolutions or a people in many
respect are a couple of elections to go
in Europe very obviously the facts of a
new era coming with the new
administration in the United States
tells us that we shall prepare for
change to come and the essence of the
change we believe is going to be more
concentration on on those issues which
really matter on the ground that is a
more pragmatic approach to issues that
have been over politicized over
ideologized for the past let me
concentrate
I suppose DT over a moment or two
specifically to Donald Trump does the EU
as a whole regard him as a threat to its
future we've heard what he said about
braixen we've heard what he said about
the EU we've heard what he said about
Angela Merkel well I most certainly as a
representative of his smaller member
state of the European would abstain from
anything like that suggesting anything
like that
we believe that respect is the first
word that should come whatever the
opinion whatever the steps that are
coming from one of the biggest countries
of the world the leading democracy of
the world you most definitely have to
respect those steps there might be and
there are certainly reasons behind those
steps that are being done and it
shouldn't be taken as a threat whatever
is coming from that direction to Europe
but as an opportunity to reengage
yourself in self investigation we've
been outspoken actually on
European issues for the past couple of
years suggesting that in the Europe
should be looking back on its own past
and future readjusting itself preparing
for the challenges that are coming may I
suggest to you that you're slightly
pulling your punches on Donald Trump
because from your country's point of
view one of the bigger threats comes
from the east comes from Russia Vladimir
Putin and the missions of that country
indeed we've seen Soviet and later
Russian behavior in different parts of
the globe but again on in that respect
just a couple of days after mr. Putin's
visit to Budapest you have to again
respect reality on the ground and in
that respect
we've called out for a reconsideration
regarding Russia because over politicize
over ideologized approaches to Russia
are not going to work we in Central
Europe Hungary specially I have to rely
on a partnership that is there you like
it or not we are still like then
European Union has never provided us the
infrastructure that could have exchanged
Russian dependence or infrastructural
dependence on say gas and oil we have to
respect that reality and that's why we
were trying and we are successful
keeping on cooperation and and talking
to each other even they in the most dire
of circumstances let me get back to the
prediction in making about a year of
revolution ahead in 2017 does a lot of
it there's nearly all of it flow from
the migrations particularly of 2015 that
puts so much strain member nations of
the European Union put so much strain on
Hungary
well migration most definitely was an
acid test of the of the European Union
institutions and member states but it's
not standing out as one or as the sole
cause of problems Europe is facing we've
seen economic problems fiscal issues
lingering around but added into that and
then you get the potential political
upheavals of populist parties saying
there's been too much migration we must
look after the people's already in our
country
well you can call it populism but the
experience on the ground especially in
Central Europe is going to be different
from the perspective of Western Europe
and one lesson actually we've learned
for the past year and a half - is that
you have to listen to the voices one
weakness of the European Union for the
past couple of years was that it was not
listening I mean the institution's
they're not listening to the voice of
smaller states who obviously have a
different perspective on issues maybe
for political economic and social legacy
reasons for other reasons that have
never been accounted for and in that
respect not only hungry but Central
Europe is having a voice by now we
believe and that's the lesson actually
of the last informal summit meeting in
Malta that
step-by-step those measures we have
introduced the the vision or the
recognition actually we have provided we
have already provided for the past two
years are being recognized on the
European level let me ask you about
brexit so when it comes to the
negotiations if article 50 is triggered
as expected by the end of March then the
negotiations can start what would the
attitude be in your country to this key
question that's going to be put to the
members of the European Union about
Britain's desires and this question is
we want we desire we must have full
control of our borders yes we also want
frictionless this is the prime
minister's words frictionless access to
the single market what your answer to
that request be yes what the answer will
be European answer in that respect
because membership in the European Union
is run on an institutional basis very
obviously Hungary has its own
perspective we were outspoken on that
and that is the security of our own
citizens working here living here on an
equal footing I think that's what we are
going to insist you but otherwise under
the direction of the Council
run by the Commission the negotiations
should be done by the 27 together okay
well I'm not sure that was yes or no can
I attempt one with the liabilities that
the UK clearly faced is going many years
forward some people are putting a figure
on it I want to ask you to put a figure
on it but would you say that the UK will
have to address fairly early on in the
negotiations that it will owe the
European Union a lot of money for many
years to come
well I would be very cautious about that
because any previous projections of what
is going to happen basically failed so
you have to be very careful about how
brags it is going to be conducted and
what the outcome of breaks it will be
and I think we've put in a term that is
that should be guiding not only for
Hungary as an individual state but again
on the 27 level we need a fair bracket
negotiations and the deal should be done
in a way we negotiated agreements should
be done in the way that that they're
going to be fair well how would you
overall describe the attitude within
Hungary to the UK and its brexit there
are rumors coming in that for in some
countries they want to administer a
punishment beating you must punish the
UK the leaving European Union to
discourage others from doing so how
would you describe the Hungarian
attitude I don't believe the Hungarian
attitude should be coming on that way or
that line at all if someone talks about
the punishment he or she is on the wrong
on the wrong track again it should be
done
I mean negotiations practise it should
be done in a fair way that is mutually
beneficial for everyone and I don't
believe that the European institutions
are in the position to detect and
timescale do you think it can be done in
the two years as detailed in article 50
as we always say responsible politicians
should know that time and if they
believe and they announced that it
should be done what could be done in a
time span it should be done and can be
done in that size plan